字幕志愿者 李宗盛
與您同步掌握
歡迎收聽
財經起床號
哈囉 各位天后大家早
歡迎大家來到
酒吧新聞台財經起床號
節目現場我是陳鳳馨
民國115年8月5號
星期三
現已經早上8點08分37秒
我們先來關心一下
今天的天氣狀況
今天全台灣各地
其實相當的穩定
當然就高溫炎熱
那麼只有少數的縣市
在今天中午前
少數的縣市
可能会有午后短暂雷震域
这几个县市是基隆市
台中市
嘉义县跟屏东县
你看这个分布其实有南有北
一北一南
基隆市然后跟屏东县
然后中部的台中市跟嘉义县
今天大概降严几率30%
比较有机会在午后
出现短暂的雷震域
其他各个县市降严几率
都是20%
包括台北市新北市桃竹苗
都是如此
所以呢各地的降雨機率
其实并不高
那今天就非常的稳定而炎热
中央气象署的预测
是北部地区跟中部地区来讲
一般来说是27到34度
南部地区呢是27到35度
但是在中午前后中央气象署呢
点名了几个限制要注意
乐让这个36度以上的高温
台北市新北市桃园市新竹县
彰化县南投县云林县台南市
屏东县还有东部地区的宜兰县跟花莲县
都有可能会出现36度以上的高温
请大家一定要特别的注意
多喝水防晒防重暑
澎湖地区呢是晴时多云
降严几率20%
白天的温度是27到32度
好
目前各个主要城市的气温
台北花莲台东29度
台中也是29度
台南高雄宜兰30度
澎湖28度
接着呢我们来看一下美国股市
美国股市呢四大指数都是上涨的
东西贵指数上涨了907点
收盤指数是54085点
涨幅1.71%
纳斯达克上涨了671点
收盤指数是26584点
涨幅2.59%
标普白指数上涨了135点
收盤指数是7736.49点
涨幅1.79%
费城半导体大涨了748点
收盘指数是12179点
涨幅6.55%
好
这一方面呢
是美国跟伊朗现在传出来呢
应该就赫姆斯海峡的开通呢
已经是有了进展了
好
虽然说伊朗否认啊
不过呢
卡达这个地方呢
是证实说
现在正在起草一个
临时协议
而协议的内容将会交由各方来审阅
所以包括了美国财政部长贝森特
还有美国国务卿路比尔都说
这一两天会达成协议
其实纽约时报是有拿到了一份的草案
他们说这份草案的内容的话
其实结果很可能就是由伊朗
来掌控赫姆兹海峡
他的规定是这样子
他說因為伊朗說他現在沒有在跟任何人談
任何的這個協議
他只有跟阿曼在談
而確實這個協議是事關於
這個伊朗跟阿曼的
那麼這個伊朗跟阿曼現在談的是說呢
所有要開入
使路這個開始進入
這個波斯灣海峽
波斯灣的所有的船舶
要行使由伊朗所掌控的
靠伊朗海岸的航道
北航道
那么如果要离开波斯湾的船舶
则是要走靠近阿曼的航线
而这项协议不会收通行费
但是会收一笔服务费
以因应航运对环境造成的影响
他的理由现在变这样
并不是通行费
那这些收入将会由伊朗跟阿曼
五五分账
所以如果这一消息是属实的话
最后达成协议
当然油价就大跌
所以我们看到今天凌晨
那么美国的期货市场当中
油价大跌了6%
这里面同时也看到了
不管是西德州原油
或者是北海布兰特原油
都下跌
跌破了80美元的关卡
目前在亚洲盘
西德州原油继续的下跌
0.88%
每一桶的报价已经来到了
75.1%
而另外一个部分呢
则是在科技公司的部分
记忆体又复活了
可能跟Chain Force
他昨天呢
那么他提出了一份报告
那么认为呢
现在在这个
不管是
记忆体DRAM
或者是快散记忆体NIFRAGE
這些PC用的記憶體呢
它其實都已經創了歷史天價
但是他們估計今年的第三季
因為AI伺服器的需求還是很強勁
所以估計呢第三季還會再漲價20%
好這是我們所看到的在
然後之後所以我們就看到說
在美股當中包括了美光大漲了7.62%
SpaceX呢
SK海力士呢
也大涨了8.17%
另外呢
Sendex呢
也涨了超过10%
Mawai也涨了将近13%
那至于在这个美股盘后呢
我们看到包括了SpaceX跟AMD
都公布了财报
其实他们的财报跟获利是优于预期的
雖然說SpaceX它還是在虧損
但它的虧損的額度是小於華爾街的預期
可即便是如此SpaceX的盤後股價呢
仍舊繼續大跌了7.46%
超微呢也下跌了8.8%
好不過在這個美股交易期間呢
台股相關的ADR呢是漲多跌少
台積電的ADR上漲了2.72%
鸿海的ADR上涨了4.19%
月光的ADR上涨了5.51%
联电的ADR大涨了10.38%
那么中华电信的ADR则下跌了1.27%
好在美股呢
非诚半导体呢
又成为了一个主涨的主要上涨的指数之后呢
台子旗的夜盘也大涨了1195点
以8月結算台子期來到了44,539點
好 那麼在今天的早報新聞
我覺得今天這個應該就是焦點中的焦點了吧
就是大家現在都在查就是
有關於中聯油脂呢
它含本品比的這一個大豆油
那麼在食藥署做了一個決策
這是7月4號的時候做了一個決策
就是含量
就這些問題油
它都已經賣給下油廠商了
那只要你的產品
含有這些問題油
低於20%的不用下架
高於20%的才要下架
其實這件事情就是引爆
整個怒火的主要原因
你要說廠商是壞蛋
然後他拼命的隱瞞
他做了問題油這件事情
這件事情呢我覺得
一般人還不會拿來直接問
問責政府
因為抓到了
然後把這個問題油的公司
好好的法辦處理
我覺得一般人其實還能夠接受
但是不能接受的是當時的處置方式
6月30號
那麼中聯油紙通報了食藥署
然後7月1號開始食藥署
就開始調查這整個事情
然後7月4號的時候做出了一個決議
20%以下不用下架
這個決定到底是怎麼做出來的
好 今天
其實我覺得最近應該是這位魏怡嘉
這位記者 中國時報的這位記者
因為我已經看到了好幾次
就是他在這個問題有的相關報導上面
他的報導其實都是跑在前面的
所以我就特別的來談一下
中國時報這一次今天的頭版頭條
主要是這位記者魏怡嘉
他取得了7月4号食药署
他的专家会议记录
在这一个专家会议记录当中
所以他里面呢
其实是有完整的出席人员
还有包括了记录的人员
主席等等等等的
他在这一份名单当中
当然这里面就做出决议
首先是
其实行政院有派人
行政院的
食安办公室主任
徐甫
在7月4号当天
参加了这一场会议
主持人是
食药署的署长
江志刚
另外还有包括了食药署的
副署长蔡孰真
另外还有
专家有7个人
食品专家3位
食用油脂加工制成专家三位
独理学专家一位
而中联油脂也有三人出席
分别是总经理于林聪
厂长陈明荣
还有品言客长陈建荣
有意思的是
其实卫福部反而没有派人
当然食药署是卫福部底下的
这一个机关
可是他是底下的
这个一级机关
所以呢
石耀署本身也是可以做决策的
署跟司
跟处是不一样的
署他有他的独立行使
行政命令的职权
结果卫福部的部长
跟次长反而没有出席
可是行政院的
石安办公室主任
徐甫
反而是出席的
所以行政院是知道的
如果我们去对照
石崇良在7月8号立法院打询的时候
他说他跟食药署官员在7月3号到行政院
向行政院长卓榮泰报告中联油脂案件
处理状况的时候
有向卓榮泰说明
依照106年2017年食药署食安资益会定出的食安分层下降原则先下架第一层油品那么卓榮泰当时的指示说应该要再考虑所以他们在7月4号举行的
专家会议而专家会议就做出了
20%的决策
所以这个专家会议到底是
谁决定的
我觉得今天呢
还会是所有问题的
焦点来
回到今天的
新闻焦点专题
我们来看中美的科技战
今天要来看的是
美国其实现在对于中国大陆的科技瓶颈
科技卡脖子来看的话呢
一般都公认是在半导体这个部分
主要是半导体的先进制程
那半导体的先进制程呢
最重要卡脖子的其实在最上游的光刻机
或者我们台湾称之为叫做曝光机
这是由艾斯摩尔所生产的曝光机
那这一个在上个
在之前呢
我们看到在上个礼拜
美国的科技媒体
The Information
它报导说
中国大陆有一家成立才三年的公司
这家公司呢叫做艾成纳
已经完成了DUV的这个机器了
而且估计今年可以量产五台
明年可以量产二十台
然後交付他們的這一些國產的半導體公司
然後來生產
我在這邊特別邀請的是
知識力科技執行長曲建仲
曲伯來了
曲伯想請教你
你覺得這個消息屬實的可能性到底高不高
OK 風險好
各位聽眾朋友大家好
其實我覺得可能性應該蠻高的
主要是因為
這一次它量產的設備是
生殖外光 浸潤式微影
那生殖外光DUV這個設備
其實目前並沒有禁運
所以其實在中國大陸的晶圓廠
當然主要是中芯國際裡面
就有很多這樣的設備
所以我覺得相關的技術
基本上也比較
大家都很熟悉了
那在這種狀況下去
設計生產這個設備的可能性是高的
那重點是
公司成立三年
但是實際上他研發一定也不只三年
他背後應該是有
我知道他們動用了很多學校的資源
讓每個學校
簡單的說就是讓光科技的每一個部件
統統有一個學校負責
大陸有14億人
那個優秀的人很多
一個學校負責一個部件
最後把這些部件整合起來
然後成立公司應該是說
他們已經到了一個程度之後才成立的
所以說是三年成立的公司
但實際上研發的時間
當然一定不只三年
或者我們可以換一個角度來講
是因為聯發已經完成了之後
才成立這家公司
我個人認為是
那另外一點就是說
他這一次的這個生子外光
競論是唯一
因為很多人只要看到生子外光
就覺得通通都一樣
就是生子外光
其實不是
同樣的生子外光的這個設備
在艾斯摩爾也有分不同等級
因為生子外光
只是指波長193奈米的
這一個孵化亞雷射產生的光
那實際上光科機的精度
是要看它其他的光學元件
整體起來的精度
所以它是有等級之分的
那它這一次量產的
其實也不可能也不是
生子外光裡面最高等級的
那各位知道生子外光最高等級的
這一個光科機
經過重複曝光之後
是可以做到7奈米製程的
7奈米以上的製程
理論上都是這樣做的
換句話說它這個光合機
實務上當然已經可以用了
但是呢
並不表示說現階段立刻就可以不需要
艾斯摩爾最先進的這種生殖外光曝光機
那另外一個重點就是我看很多報導
當然實際的狀況我不清楚
但是我認為報導是可信的
也就是這個設備裡面的
某些關鍵性的零組件可能還是鏡頭
這個很正常
今天老闆跟我說叫我研發一台光合機
那我大概就是能國產的就去找嘛
找不到國產怎麼辦
我要讓設備盡快上線
因為公司要賺錢嘛
那當然我就先跟國外買
只要能買到
先把機器湊起來
湊起來之後確定可以用了
那未來再慢慢把這些零件換成國產
我覺得它的策略一定是這樣
所以簡單的說這台光刻機
我預估大概能做到的製程就是
屬於成熟製程裡面
接近先進製程的
那大概就是10奈米以上
可以做到10奈米也很厲害
其實我認為是這樣
那10奈米以下還是用生子外光
但是我認為可能還是得依賴
艾斯莫爾最先進的設備
那你覺得這裡面最關鍵性的零組件
最難突破的可能性的
這一些項目是什麼
其實非常多啦
那曝光機因為它是穿透式的光源
所以我想第一個就是
雷射相關的系統
但是雷射這個東西
中國大陸其實做得非常好
所以我認為這個部分
他們自己做的可能性不低
反而是台灣做雷射這個領域
是非常落後
我必須非常明確的說
台灣幾乎沒有一家
做高功率雷射的廠商
換句話說這個關鍵的技術
我們完全是掌握在國外的
這個廠商手中
那我一直強調
因為雷射是基礎工業
這個東西要非常非常的重視
但是因為競爭在市場上
中國大陸有很多雷射廠商
台灣很難跟它競爭
所以大家也都不想做
反正就買進口的就算了
另外一個光合機
真正難的其實是它裡面的光學系統
我認為光學系統很複雜
光學系統裡面包含那些透鏡
還有零鏡還有一些特殊的光學元件
對準要對得很準
然後還有它的這個機械裝置
就是那個控制這個晶圓跟
這個光學系統之間
對位的精度很高的這些零組件
這很多東西非常的精密
那我認為應該有一部分
那個廠商也是靠國外進口的來做
所以雷射的部分
它是這裡面的核心
可是你覺得中國大陸突破的機率高
但是在光學系統的部分
其實在當初荷蘭艾斯莫爾他也是高度的跟德國的蔡斯合作
才在關學系統上面有一點點的突破
所以關學系統突破其實困難度非常的高
是還有精密機械就是我剛剛說對準
其實大致上就這三個
所以精密機械這三件事情
好所以呢我們現在要看說
你剛剛講說成立才三年
關鍵點是他們可能已經研發完成了才成立這一家公司
那所以我們就要來看的是
那後續它會不會有其他的研發動作
其實是大家沒有看到的
要等到成品一出來才讓大家嚇一跳
你所收集到的資料來看的話
可能有哪一些
其實因為你剛剛講了
這一次的生子外光浸潤式曝光機
其實它並不是最先進的DUV
更不要講說就先進資產來講
最需要的EUV
那就你知道的話
或者就你所看到的一些资讯来看的话
他们现在在哪部分
现在正在寻求突破
以中国大陆的策略
一定是全部自己做
因为当它全部自己做的时候
那竞争力会非常非常的强
就是这种产业的一条龙
那事实上台湾的厂商
要增加竞争力
也必须做这件事
我必须要实说
其实台积电现在
也在努力的做一条龙
是
那回到这个中国大陆现在状况
就是他们这个
竞润是生殖外光的曝光机
他们一定还会持续调高精度
慢慢能够做到跟艾斯莫尔一样
也就是我刚刚说10奈米制程以下
能够用的这种设备
这是一条线
那另外一条线就是大家很有兴趣的
就是极紫外光
那极紫外光目前是用那个
雷射深层电浆的方式
各位知道它是用那个锡的易滴
然后用雷射光去撞击产生极紫外光
但实际上产生极紫外光还有其他的方式
包括用同步辐射的方式
包括用这个
放電的方式
放電深層電漿的方式
那這三個方向
基本上我知道
中國大陸都有在做
那這個部分
一定是壓著滑水
只是說它的難度
因為太高了
所以我認為
這個還需要時間
所以 maybe
我覺得至少
還要5到8年以上的時間
過一陣子可能
大家又
他們又宣布
有這樣的技術
所以只要是曝光相關的技術
這個都是半導體先進製程
或者微小縮小製程
非常重要的關鍵技術
所以他們一定壓著滑水
都已經在做相關的研發
你剛剛講說其實呢
就EUV當中最重要的
那一個光源的
那一個角色
有電漿對不對
雷射電漿
雷射深層電漿
還有放電深層電漿
放電深層電漿
就類似日光燈那個概念
還有同步輻射
當年ISMOL應該是三種
也都是試著
這個技術大概是在2020年
科學界就在討論了
那這三種技術大家都試過
那最後呢
用這個雷射深層電漿
是最後決定價格啦
尺寸啊
各方面條件適合量產的技術
對
我們稍微休息一下
我們馬上回來節目現場
因為還不只是這個問題
還有套定律的問題
水修的
對啊,20%
新政院知道
沒有,我是要跟你說為什麼他們做這個決策
哦
說是說為什麼要
以科學的角度
對啦
他做這個決策
我能理解
可是說真的就是科學的角度
跟一般人的生活感受是差別非常大的
你知道就是說
他的問題有含量20%一下
如果當我們從科學角度是OK的話
其实结果就会是
那我生活里头买回沙拉油
我做出来的菜
也不可能20%以上
不是这样看的
不过anyway我觉得这个
我们结束之后再谈论
所以我觉得这个是民众在
心里头没办法接受的
它会变成一种就是
劣币驱逐良币
我在市场上所看到
所有我都不相信
这个真的就是一个心理问题了
其实关键点还是在那个前面的那个原料
那个热损率提高到5%这件事情
它确实影响还蛮大的
從這角度來講
艾斯莫爾其實沒有什麼好擔心的
為什麼
他會擔心啊
你真的覺得他會擔心
當然啊
因為時間不是還久嗎
他明後年要賣DUV
賣進大陸是上百台
這都是他的營收
如果中國都自己做
那他的營收會有影響
但是我認為沒有很大的影響
但是會有影響
他其實怕的是長期
其实市场在反映的也是长期
它绝对不是反映明年
它反映的是那五到十年呢
通訊大陸很有意思的
就雖然說艾斯莫爾當年選擇的是雷射深層電漿
但是他還是希望能夠在同步輻射
或者放電深層電漿上面可能突破
可以聊一下
欢迎大家回到
酒吧新闻台财经请床
好请不现场
我是陈凤馨
今天的新闻焦点专题
来看的是
中国大陆能不能够
成功的突破美国的封锁
其实曝光机
是一个非常重要的一环
我们今天特别邀请的是
知识力科技执行长
曲建仲曲博
来跟大家好好谈一谈这个话题
先从The Information
他报导说
他大陆的爱成纳
这个成立三年的公司
今年就渴望量产五台的
浸润式生子外光DUV
那么明年渴望生产20台
那刚刚在我们现场曲博说
他认为这个可能性是非常高的
當然它不到最高階的DUV
但是呢
它進一步調教這個DUV
然後讓它可以進一步的
可以生產到10奈米以下的一些
可能7奈米的這樣子的一個
這個先進製程的可能性
是很高的
但是呢
接下來就看的是
真正跟先進製程
5奈米啦
3奈米啦
2奈米啦
真正影響的是EUV
可是剛剛曲伯提到說EUV的
它的光的來源
就跟DUV完全不同了
它用的是雷射深層電漿
可是當初其實艾斯莫爾在選擇的時候
是有三條路的
雷射深層電漿
同步輻射
以及放電深層電漿
那中國大陸現在是三條路
同時去測試
如果艾斯莫爾已經嘗試了
第一條路是對的
為什麼會
中國大陸要三條路要測
這三條路各有各的優缺點
那放電深層電漿
就有點類似我們那個日光燈的概念
就是我用電去激發產生這個光
那問題出在這個東西產生的光太弱了
我們先談談現有的這個雷射深層電漿有什麼缺點
它現在是用那個錫啊
錫是一種金屬啊 溶點很低啊
加熱之後融化之後呢
變一滴一滴的再用雷射去撞
去產生那個極子外光
它的效率是比較高的
可是那個錫它變成液體的時候
它會污染那個系統
因為氣體溶點又低一定會發生
可是它效率高啊
那看起來這個是可行的
那放電濕能電漿呢
因為它沒有這種污染的問題
可問題就是它發出來的光太弱
那你光一弱的話
你曝光的時間就要長
那個光阻才會反映
所以這個就是它的缺點
但是我知道世界各地
還是有很多科學家
不停的在想辦法
用放電深層電漿去提高它的效率
能夠發出更強的光
這樣就可以取代原來的技術
所以光電在你的放電能夠產生多大的能量
對 關鍵就是你要想辦法增加那個能量
也就是能量密度要夠高
你才有辦法聚集起來變成雷射光
然後讓它能夠在合理的時間完成曝光
那中國大陸在這方面
他們其實相關的研究其實是比較多的
基本上都有投入啦
不是只有中国大陆
我相信连艾斯蒙自己都有在研究
因为原来这个雷射智能电箱确实有缺点
研究这种东西就要持续进行
同步辐射其实是另外一个可行的
因为同步辐射它是用一个电子绕一个非常大的圆周
台湾在新竹有一个同步辐射中心
那个圆周大概200公尺
我有点忘了精确的数字
200公尺其实是超长那么大
你让电子绕圈圈的时候
它沿著切線方向就會放出同步輻射
那個能量是夠高的
但問題來了就是說你要
做晶圓的製造
結果要搞一個200公尺的同步輻射
這個在實務上就面臨體積龐大
而且成本過高的問題
所以假設今天中國大陸不計成本
我就是要做出來的話
其實我認為用同步輻射的可能性
是有的
那意思就是說
技術上跟成本要雙重考量
那一般民間企業要考量兩個的時候
就只能選艾斯莫爾現在的方案
那我能夠縮小同步輻射的體積嗎
這個問題又來了
你同步輻射體積縮小能量就會降低
那所以這個是魚與熊掌
他們應該會做一個適當的尺寸
那我認為也不需要到200公尺
因為200公尺的同步輻射是實驗用的
那你只要產生足夠能量
可以做曝光就可以
好 這個只是光源
所以你會發現這個光源
比剛剛我們講那個生殖外光的光源
就複雜很多了
那光源突破之后
再来就是光学系统
又回到刚刚的问题了
精度
然后精密机械对准的精度
那这些东西都必须要克服
所以我认为
发展极致外光这个时间
我刚刚说大概八年
五到八年算客气啦
甚至更长的时间都是合理的
因为这东西难度是真的比较高
好
所以呢
DUV的突破
对于爱斯莫尔来讲
那时候曾经造成的市场很大的紧张
但大家算了之后发现说
目前為止影響還小
關鍵點還是在於
大家擔心的是
當你的國產DUV可以生產
然後接著是量產
當你量產到了一定程度的時候
整個中國大陸的市場
其實DUV市場就等於是
它的國產自主完整了
這個對愛斯摩
以及相關的這些原料啊
這些影響其實是存在
可是EUV還是後階段了
對 因為愛斯摩目前大部分的營收是EUV
對 因為那個比較貴啊
比較貴啊
真的是收入很好
我個人認為有影響
但是影響不至於大到整個
大家覺得非常嚴重
如果他真的在五年之內EUV有進展
會讓你嚇一跳嗎
會
因為我個人認為那個難度真的非常高
所以
大家都知道艾斯莫爾做出EUV
也不是艾斯莫爾一家的功勞
那是好多家
艾斯莫爾只是組裝起來
而且我聽說連組裝
都是一件非常非常困難的事
沒錯沒錯
而且組裝的過程當中
其實都必須要有他的客戶
一起來調教的
所以包括了台積電啊 三星啊
英特爾那個時候
其實不但是投入資金
然後同時他們有投資喔
投資而且他們還投入人力
協助調教 對
所以那個過程非常困難
為了這件事情呢
他們去要求蔡司 德國蔡司
獨立成立一家子公司
然後呢他們入股那一家
蔡司獨立出來的子公司
所以你就知道它的複雜程度
跨國合作
好那
這是曝光機的部分
不過在尋求突破
除了曝光機光刻機之外
在先進封裝的部分
華為在5月的時候推出了
TAU定律
你怎麼解讀這個TAU定律
對我稍微說明一下
目前的整個半導體
都是要朝向把電晶體做小
那原因很簡單
因為電晶體越小
代表這個運算的過程中
電子移動的距離就縮短
那當然速度就會變快
這就是所謂的摩爾定律
那因為過去這幾十年
大家都被限制在這個框框裡面了
所以大家就是拼命把它做小
那華為我常說他們的科學家是很聰明
其實各位去看我的YouTube
很多網友跟我嗆聲
那些嗆聲的人是因為他們沒有真的跟華為工作過
因為我以前在外商公司
那我的同事呢
那時候是專門去跟
資源華為一起工作的
那甚至我也去他們的深圳總部看過
所以這間公司很多故事
那個都是我同事跟我聊過的
一手資料啊
我先講我們在電子五哥當中
有一家公司
他們有成立華為專案
就專門去研究華為這家公司
不是去跟他打交道而已喔
是研究華為這家公司
那個年代因為沒有封鎖這件事
所以本來交流就很正常
那總之大家永遠記得
華為是一間非常有競爭力的公司
任何科技公司都要非常嚴肅的對待這件事
當我們在談華為什麼東西做得很好的時候
我大部分得到的反應就是我在幫人家吹捧
真的不是這樣
業內都知道我們必須隨時了解他們的進度
所以他們就想到一個方法
我要讓運算速度變快
為什麼一定是把電晶體縮小
為什麼不是把電晶體跟電晶體中間的
導線那個距離縮短
那問題要怎麼縮短
因為我們現在設計的晶片都是
在同一個晶片上有非常多電晶體
然後再用金屬導線把它連起來
那有的時候因為那個
一個平面就好像平房一樣
你這個電晶體跟那個電晶體
你要連起來可是距離就有點遠
你要把它縮起來也沒辦法縮
因為旁邊都是其他電晶體
那最簡單的方法就像大樓一樣疊起來
所以他們就想到了那很簡單
這個電晶體本來距離很遠
那如果把這個電晶體
放到另外一個晶片上
然後用兩個晶片垂直疊起來
那兩個晶片垂直疊起來的
那個距離是不是就縮短了
所以他們就想到用這個方法
換句話說不要再去談電晶體縮小
這個所謂的摩爾定律
我們要去談的是讓
電晶體跟電晶體之間
通訊的時間縮短
那時間常數我們把它叫 tau
所以呢就把這個東西稱為 tau定律
實際上他們實作
我最近有看到他們發表華為的論文
第二版就是他們實測
因為他們下半年就要量產
的一些測試數據
這個很明顯代表
用這個方式確實有效
確實有效它的做法也很簡單
就把兩個晶片在設計的階段
就要分開設計
應該說是整合成一個晶片來設計的概念
但是把原來要放在同一個晶片上的標準單元
把它拆成兩個
分到兩個晶片上
這樣子疊起來的時候
才能達到那個效果
就是我之前在平面當中
我會建立那個電源導線的
兩個晶片
我從一開始在設計的時候
就把它設計在
立體的臨近的地方
是 那這樣我在用先進風裝的方式
把它堆起來
那就可以把那個導線
從原來你要走一段很長的距離
變成你要走到上
就好像我們一樓爬到二樓
那一樓爬到二樓的距離就比你原來在同一個晶片上要走的距離就縮短很多
而且它一樓到二樓不是三公尺
它一樓到二樓就是跟一個晶片的寬度一樣
一個一層薄膜的厚度啦
所以那個就變成是奈米等級的東西
好 我知道其實陶定律提出來之後
很多人就會講說
那台積電本來就有先進封裝啊
先進封裝本來就已經是堆疊啦
那就跟先進封裝沒有跟COVAS沒有什麼兩樣
對 所以要分開來看這件事
目前台積電做的都還是同一個晶片上去設計
然後呢 想辦法把它縮小
那華為它現在變成是在設計的時候
所以這個東西就牽扯到上游的EDA
電子設計自動化工具
你在設計的時候就必須要把
原來在同一個晶片上的標準單元
一個標準單元就有很多電晶體
你就要把它設計的時候就要知道說
我要分成兩個晶片來設計
所以這件事情
牽扯到不是只有製程
它牽扯到上游的設計
所以這就回到華為
現在大部分的設計工具都是Cadence或Synesis
對不對
但是他們沒有這樣的設計工具啊
所以代表什麼
代表他們跟華大九天一定有合作
提供新的設計工具才有辦法達到
所以我們稍微休息一下它最大的差別就在於從設計階段就必须要符合涛定律那谁来设计呢马上回来其实这件事情呢
我知道在一些半导体界的人反而更关心
主要的原因是因为
他们也知道摩尔定律已经到了极限了
他終究到了物理極限
到了物理極限
你要再尋求更快的速度
然後更有效率的一個做法
他就勢必要走一個不同的方式
所以其實你不管
有沒有先進晶片的這個晶片
其實掏定率都看起來是必然要走的
應該說現在台灣在做先進日能這些人
一定也會去留意這個新聞
你剛剛講的沒有錯
確實將來先進製程沒辦法再縮小
那把同一個標準單元的電晶體
分到兩個晶片去堆疊
確實是一個方向
但是呢
越先進的製程要做這件事情
它的意義就越小
那這個是有原因的
原因是因為你用先進封裝
我們待會可以談一下這個
你用先進封裝去堆晶片
是不是代表你要做那個金屬柱
把兩個晶片連起來
目前的先進封裝
它的精度大概就是做到微米等級而已
那就代表說
你在兩個晶片上你要打幾萬個孔
而且每個孔都是微米等級
那微米等級在先進製程那是很大的
那換句話說你兩個晶片是不是就有很多位置
都要浪費去做那個金屬柱子
所以這個時候你用奈米等級的晶片就沒有意義了
對 所以這個是很重要的觀念
這個其實要很深的去了解這個技術才會講到那麼深
所以簡單的講就是華為現在這麼做是不得已的
因為它的製程就是7奈米以上
那7奈米以上做這件事是有意義的
但是當你的製程是2奈米1奈米的時候
再去做這件事到底有沒有意義
我不敢說一定沒有
換句話說就是在食物上可能又要做一些變化
就是你剛剛講的那個導線又必須要再縮小才行
要嘛就是先進封裝的那個柱子
你就想你的就好像大樓你要做蓋高樓一定有柱子
它那是幾萬個柱子
然後那個柱子又很粗
為什麼因為它是微米等級
你說要做到奈米等級可不可以呢
又遇到你兩個金片要對準
他微米等級要對都很難對
那米等級對不起來
所以這件事情只能說
先進制成的人一定會去注意這個新聞
但是到底適不適用不知道
這個我覺得是接下來大家要去討論
所以就算說我看到了淘定律
然後就算說他們已經把
一些的工具也研發出來了
然後呢他們的軟體設計
從一開始就可以符合淘定律
可是對不起我這邊先進制成
可能都沒辦法直接應用
一秒都陪伴著你
全世界news you bye
Ella
欢迎大家回到酒吧新闻台财经请床
好 节目现场我是陈凤馨
能不能突破美国的封锁
其实半导体是一个最重要的关键
那对台湾来讲也是影响重大
那突破的入境呢
其实有两种
一种就是
那个卡在上游的那个曝光机
那我就坐到
那个最上游的那个曝光机
我也可以做最先进制程的晶片
这是其中一个方法
另外所以我们看到DUV的这个新闻
它在国际上面就影响非常的大
但是它距离EUV还有一大段距离
我们刚刚提到
但是华为的套定律
那是一条路径
那一条路径是
我如果在平面上面
我再缩小我的晶片
我没有办法
因为先进制程的这个EUV我拿不到
所以我没办法做先进制程的晶片
没关系
我就用它變成立體型的
而這個立體型的
也不是簡單的就是
我把它堆疊起來而已
因為我們現在的COVA
先進封裝
其實就是堆疊起來
它的方式是必須我在
一開始我在設計
這個晶片的功能的時候
我就必須要把
設計的時候去思考
它不是走平面
它是走立體
那立體的那條路線
每一個晶片的功能
要如何的拆分
然後如何的合作
他的設計的方法
就完全跟現在的
這種軟體設計的
EDA的這種軟體設計工具
是完全不同的
因此我們如果用
美國的那兩家
軟體設計公司的EDA
是根本不可能
做出這件事情的
目前是
那就代表著
華為要尋求的是
中國大陸自己的
EDA公司
自己要帶來
這一部分的突破
對 所以它其實是一個產業鏈
從上游的設計一直到後面的
設計工具一直到後面的設計過程
一直到最後的製程
通通都要串起來才行
所以坦白說這個
一旦全部串起來之後也是很可怕
很有競爭力
那大家就會想說
如果我今天用這樣的方式
在7nm以上的晶片去增加這個運算的效能
那目前我看到的數字是確實已經有效果
換句話說下半年的這個晶片量產
那很多這個網友就嗆聲說
只是嘴巴說
我覺得這件事情很簡單
因為手機一旦量產
晶片賣出去之後
大家就會測了
歐美一定有很多專門猜測
我們到時候就看測試報告
Take inside
測完還會切開
還用電子顯微鏡看過
就是這種東西一翻兩瞪眼
到時候就可以證實這個狀況
那問題是它那個理念
它那理念確實是新的
那問題又來了
那目前台灣
就是台積電這些廠商用的先進製程
真的只是把晶片堆起來
那有沒有可能也引用濤定律
理論上
因為剛剛鳳馨有提到嘛
就是你現在電晶體要縮小
確實越來越困難了
那或許用晶片堆起來是一個方法
但是呢
晶片堆起來也有它的限制
它主要的問題是這樣
因為你把同一個標準單元的電晶體
拆成兩個晶片
那就代表先進封裝
上下晶片的金屬柱子会暴增
目前的这个一般先进封装的金屬柱
上下对起来大概就是几千支金屬柱
一个晶片
但是呢你要用套定律的话
会上万好多万支的金屬柱
那各位知道先进封装那个金屬柱子
就像我们的房子的那个柱子一样
那个要缩小很困难
原因是因为先进封装的晶片对位
是用机械的方式来对位
那用機械方式對位
它現在的精度大概就做到微米等級
所以你的柱子也沒辦法奈米化
對
那因為各位可能對微米沒感覺
我們的頭髮是100微米
所以細菌大概是1微米
所以你等於要把兩支細菌對得很準
這個難度已經很高了
那你要再縮小到奈米等級
那是病毒
你要把兩支病毒對準
這個難度太高
所以目前的先進制成
能對的大概就是微米等級
所以並不是我那個金屬柱架
能不能再纳米化
問題是那個對準技術上面
它本身就有它的困難
以自成來說
柱子要縮小不是問題
問題是你要對準
這就是很大的問題
所以台積電也面臨這一部分
先進封裝的精度的困難
必須克服
好那同樣來了
你有幾萬支金屬柱
代表那個柱子的地方
是沒有電晶體的
所以你大概就想像
兩個晶片上有幾萬個點
是不能有電晶體
必须要浪費來那個面積來做這個金屬柱子
才能夠把兩個晶片對起來
好 問題又來了
那未來的先進製程
比如說3奈米 2奈米 甚至1奈米
能不能用高定域來做呢
那就面臨同樣的問題
當你的電晶體已經縮到這麼小了
結果你要浪費幾萬個位置
而且是微米等級的
然後呢 要來留著做柱子
不能做電晶體
那是浪費晶片的面積耶
所以我觉得这件事情不知道结局怎么样
总之这些真正做先进封装的厂商
一定会因为华为提出的涛定律
开始去研究说有没有可能用涛定律
来解决这种晶片先进制程的瓶颈问题
没有办法再缩小的问题
但是在这个讨论研究的过程中
必须要克服的就是说
先进封装的这个技术
有没有办法再提升
让它做这个柱子的时候
不要做那麼粗
可不可以縮小
不只是柱子要變奈米化
甚至於包括了
它的對準方式
也要有奈米級的對準方式
但不管怎麼說
這是一個新的概念
那我認為
原來做先進製成的這些廠商
包含台積電在內
一定也會去討論這個問題
學術界一定也會很有興趣
去討論這個問題
但是我覺得
從這件事情就看出來
華為這間公司
是很有創造力的
真的是很強大的競爭對手
所有的限制都能帶來突破
這個就是只有你要不要
可不可能
只有你願不願意
所以你覺得這件事情突破的機率
反而相對比較高一點
對 華為來說
它現在用這樣的方式
那我認為下半年它就要量產
那它雖然有一些
它們內部測的數據
我看過確實是有達到它們的目標
那它們還有第二階段
第三階段會持續
一直到它把極紫外光EUV
做出來為止
它都必須用這個方法來追趕
那大家可能會很好奇
所以兩條路的追趕都還在進行
那大家會好奇說
那這樣會不會超越台積電
因為很多新聞都寫說這個
華為用濤定率
來超越台積電的1.4奈米
我認為這個基本上不會
因為目前的狀況用先進製程去萎縮
還有可以看到的效益
但是各位要記得現在的先進製程
越萎縮那個效益是越低
但不管怎麼說還是有那個效益
換句話說華為
本來美國政府可能認為說
我只要卡住你的極紙外光
你大概就永遠停在7奈米製程
不會再進步了
那我們一直在進步嘛
那7奈米是台積電什麼時候就做出來
應該是2020年吧
就已經或者更早就已經量產的東西
換句話說時間越推進
差距就越大
但是呢人家沒想到用這個套定律之後呢
它還是持續在進步
雖然那進步的速度沒有那麼快
但是呢
差距並沒有如美國想像的說會越來越大
我認為那個差距就是持續保持甚至縮短的可能性都很高
韜定律剛剛你提到說
因為它並不是說我一個概念出來了
堆疊好像就解決了一切
沒有它這裡面其實是一系列的產業鏈的全速的調整
從最上游的IC設計公司
以及它所使用的EDA的軟體工具
然後乃至於這裡面呢
就包括了剛剛提到的就是
這裡面的金屬架
然後還有包括這裡面的堆疊的時候
你當然不可能讓晶片跟晶片碰在一起
晶片跟晶片中間是要玻璃窄板
對不對
那這一連串其實都必須要是整個產業鏈
全部的去調整去適配它
那這些適配如果完成了
別人要再追趕容易嗎
我覺得技術上其他廠商也會努力也會進步
所以我覺得大家就是各自兄弟登商各自努力
問題是出在當中國大陸可以把整個產業一條龍的時候
他那個成本競爭力會很嚇人
所以現在的狀況可能我覺得台灣廠商也不用太擔心
因為美國現在就是要搞什麼所謂的這個飛鴻供應鏈
所以我想以上業的行為台灣廠商還是有機會
只是说以竞争力来谈
会非常可怕
好这就是中美的半导体科技战
谢谢曲博
也要谢谢大家
谢谢
拜拜